[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Álvaro cordero
Este 27 de octubre se cumplen 100 años
de la marcha sobre Roma un episodio en
el que decenas de miles de fascistas
tomaron el poder en Italia bajo las
órdenes de Benito Mussolini un evento
que contó con el apoyo del entonces
monarca Víctor Manuel tercero y que
convirtió a Mussolini en Primer Ministro
la marcha sobre Roma marca el origen del
primer país fascista en Europa algo que
con los años traería consecuencias en
todo el continente es por ello que en
fanas 24 repasamos lo que fue la Italia
fascista de Benito Mussolini
los orígenes de este militar italiano
están sorprendentemente en una familia
con una alta influencia socialista y
sindicalista pero aunque militó en el
partido socialista italiano durante su
juventud tras la Primera Guerra Mundial
se alejó de esos postulados Mussolini
participó como soldado en esta contienda
y fue muy crítico con los escasos
beneficios que había obtenido Italia
tras esta capitalizando un descontento
general que lo llevaría a crear el
Partido Nacional fascista sus militantes
conocidos Como camisas negras sembraron
el terror durante meses contra líderes
de izquierda y se ganaron la simpatía de
empresarios burgueses y la clase media
italiana que temía una Revolución
comunista sobre este apoyo pudo
organizar la marcha sobre Roma una
concentración de miles de fascistas
italianos en todo el país que se dirigió
hacia la capital con el objetivo de
presionar al rey Víctor Manuel III para
que como Primer Ministro a Benito
Mussolini una estrategia que funcionó a
pesar de que Mussolini no había
cosechado prácticamente votos en las
elecciones de 1921 en sus primeros años
de gobierno fue controlando
progresivamente todas las instituciones
del estado hasta que su poder Total como
dictador se consolidó tras las
elecciones de 1924 en estos comicios el
partido fascista obtuvo la mayoría
absoluta tras una campaña de violencia
contra opositores y de amaños algo que
levantó las protestas del partido
socialista y de su líder ya como
mateotti quien tras recibir amenazas de
Mussolini fue asesinado por militantes
fascistas a los pocos días tras el
asesinato se legalizaron todos los
partidos e Italia Se confirmó como una
dictadura
Mussolini pasó a ser conocido como El
Duche y comenzó a regir Italia bajo un
mando personalista adaptado a los
principales puntos defendidos por el
fascismo esta ideología es contraria a
la democracia y al comunismo y defiende
un elevado militarismo en el que prima
la violencia como herramienta de
destrucción de cualquier voz disidente
el fascismo adaptado por Benito
Mussolini eliminó cualquier tipo de
libertad individual y los eventos
multitudinarios de exaltación al líder y
símbolos históricos como el saludo a la
Romana que posteriormente sería adoptado
como un saludo fascista fueron
constantes al igual que las proclamas
que defendían engrandecer a Italia de
nuevo a través de la creación de un
imperio colonial
durante las primeras décadas del siglo
XX las colonias italianas en África eran
limitadas En comparación con potencias
como Reino Unido o Francia ya que
solamente tenían Bajo su poder alivia
eritrea y la somalia Italiana posesiones
más que insuficientes que hicieron que
la dictadura de Benito Mussolini
comenzará una guerra en octubre de 1935
contra abisinia la actual Etiopía
Italia lanzó una operación Relámpago en
la que se cometieron crímenes de guerra
y masacres contra la población e incluso
se llegó a usar armas químicas algo que
le valió la condena de la Sociedad De
Naciones pero que la acercó a un nuevo
Aliado la Alemania de adolf Hitler estas
dos naciones llegaron a la Segunda
Guerra Mundial como aliadas Aunque en un
principio Mussolini dudó en dar su apoyo
a Hitler cuando inició la Guerra en
Polonia finalmente tomó la decisión en
junio de 1940 mientras Francia estaba
siendo invadida al pensar que la
victoria en Europa estaba prácticamente
asegurada para Alemania Italia comenzó
una serie de invasiones a otras naciones
como Albania y Grecia y a territorios
coloniales de Reino Unido Aunque pronto
comenzó a demostrar sus limitaciones y a
necesitar la constante asistencia
alemana debido al mal equipamiento
militar y a la desorganización Italiana
la situación empeoró aún más cuando el
curso de la guerra cambió y Alemania
empezó a retroceder a partir de 1943 el
9 de julio de ese año los aliados
realizaron un desembarco masivo en el
sur de Italia y comenzaron a tomar
varias ciudades algo que hizo que el rey
Víctor Manuel III Viera peligrar su
continuidad por su tolerancia al
fascismo y que decidiera destituir y
detener a Benito Mussolini para unirse a
los aliados este movimiento provocó el
inicio de una guerra civil en Italia que
es el libro de forma paralela a la
contienda mundial Y aunque Mussolini
estuvo en prisión durante un tiempo fue
liberado por tropas alemanas en una
operación especial
Mussolini pasó a comandar la República
de saló un estado títere fascista al
norte de Italia con presencia del
ejército alemán que dependía totalmente
de las directrices de Berlín para ese
momento Mussolini había perdido
cualquier tipo de Independencia y Su
futuro estaba ligado al de la Alemania
nazi y aldeadolf Hitler con el colapso
Alemán en 1945
Mussolini se vio obligado a huir de
incógnito para intentar salvar su vida
ante el avance de los aliados y de los
partisanos italianos Aunque finalmente
no pudo evitar la muerte mientras
intentaba cruzar a Suiza Mussolini fue
reconocido por un partisano italiano y
detenido junto a su amante Clara petacci
El dictador fue fusilado el 28 de abril
de 1945 y su cadáver fue expuesto
públicamente en Milán y linchado por una
multitud furiosa que hizo que quedara
prácticamente irreconocible su final
trajo la democracia de nuevo Italia
Aunque la sombra de Mussolini perduró
como influencia de algunos políticos de
la extrema derecha italiana como su
actual primera ministra Georgia meloni
con esto concluimos Gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]